- [Voiceover] So, grammarians,
if you're a native
English speaker, the phrase
French old white house
might seem a little weird to
you, if you're not a native
English speaker it might
not, and this is something
that I didn't really know about
before I started preparing
to teach this course, is that
there is a specific order
that adjectives go in in English.
This is something that
I think we just pick up
as English speakers but if
you didn't grow up speaking
English it gets a little tricky sometimes.
So the question is, in order
to make this seem right,
what order do you put these adjectives in?
That's near about as I can reckon it.
Making this into old white French house.
Because there is an order
and it goes like this.
Determiner, opinion, size,
age, shape, color, origin,
material, purpose, or
for short dosa scomp.
Dosa scomp. Aw.
Okay, that's actually kind of a thing.
So a dosa is a South Indian
flat bread, and a scomp,
I'm gonna say is a word for eating.
It's not a word, it's a made
up word, but dosa scomp.
Sounds like scarf to me.
Or chomp.
Both of those are verbs that denote
eating, as well as scarf
being a garment, so dosa scomp.
I just want you to imagine
sitting down to a delicious
South Indian meal and
scomping on some dosas.
So dosa scomp.
Determiner, and that's
words like the or an.
Opinion, this is when you're
describing something there are
certain descriptors that not
everyone would agree with.
So if you're looking at a
piece of black metal, everyone
would be able to agree that it is black.
But if you think it's cool
looking or ugly looking,
you know, everything that anyone
could conceivably disagree
about, that's an opinion.
So, cool for example,
that would be an opinion.
Size, so the cool, big,
old, square, black,.
And origin usually can be where it's from.
So let's say Texan.
And then we have materials,
let's say leather, cause leather
can be black, and the purpose.
This is where we would use
what's called a participle
or a gerundive to determine
what the thing is for.
So if we were talking
about a lawnmower that you
ride around on, that's
called a riding mower.
And the last thing here
is the thing itself.
So we're looking at, so this
thing is cool, big, old,
square, black, Texan, leather,
riding mower, but frankly
in most normal English
sentences you'll probably never
going to use more than
three adjectives to describe
a given thing.
Like old white French house.
Now sometimes, you might
find yourself using more than
one adjective that fits
into the same category.
So you might say the exciting,
unparalleled green dragon.
And you'll notice I put a comma
there, because when you use
two adjectives from the same
category, so two opinions,
exciting and unparalleled,
you wanna separate them with
a comma, but generally if
you're just scooting down the
dosa scomp, old white French
house, you don't need to
separate these non-coordinate
adjectives from each other.
And we'll get more into
commas in punctuation section,
but for now, all you need
to remember is dosa scomp.
And if you've never had a
dosa, I strongly urge you to
look up recipes online or go
to a South Indian restaurant
and make and eat this delicious food.
And then, you're just
gonna scomp on some dosas.
So determiner, opinion, size, age, dosa.
Shape, color, origin, material,
purpose, and then the thing.
That's the order that
adjectives go in in English.
Why is this? I have no idea.
You know sometimes language can be really,
the word I tend to use is arbitrary.
You can call it random, if you like.
This is just the way that
we arrived at this order,
it's just basically through
random chance of convention.
And what seems to sound right.
And what sounds right for
English isn't always what sounds
right for other languages.
For example, the way we're
using adjectives here,
we're always putting them
to the left of whatever they
modify, the exciting,
unparalleled green dragon.
It's all to the left, it's
all old white French house.
It's all on this one side of it.
And other languages don't
do that necessarily.
So when you're trying to just
throw a bunch of adjectives
together on the left side of
the noun, this is the order.
Just remember dosa scomp.
And that's how adjective
order works in English.
You can learn anything.
David out.